[Music]
covid19 cases are surging in myanmar
after six months of military rule only
40 percent of its healthcare facilities
are open
[Music]
doctors and nurses led a civil
disobedience movement against the
military takeover
drawing the ire of the junta
now many medical staff are afraid to
turn up to work
further straining myanmar's beleaguered
hospitals
test and trace systems are faltering due
to public mistrust in the new
establishment
faith in medical care is waning
further boosting kovid's spread
faced with such difficulty myanmar
citizens are finding their own ways to
care for each other
this is your kovid 19 special here on dw
i'm janelle demala
and as people in myanmar find themselves
unable to rely on public services to
help them deal with a surge other
sectors of society are stepping in to
fill the void including places of
worship
it's just after dawn in yangon myanmar's
largest city
in front of this mosque the line for
oxygen refills slowly shuffles forward
people have already been waiting for
hours
desperate for medical oxygen
for loved ones with covid19
if we want to get oxygen we have to come
here early even though i came here at
around four in the morning i had to
stand back in the line as some people
had already arrived
for many in myanmar treating covid19 is
a do-it-yourself project
oxygen and hospital beds are scarce
the mosque decided to offer oxygen as a
way to help
initially we thought of distributing
meals to covid quarantine centers like
we did last year
but we changed our decision as we saw
people in desperate need of medical
oxygen
it's available here free of charge
religion ethnic background doesn't
matter
all who wait are served
it's a lifeline as most people here
can't afford to pay
prices have more than tripled with the
infection surge
the military government has not been
able to effectively manage the health
crisis
authorities are now even forcing oxygen
factories to close
so we're struggling to get enough
supplies to refill the oxygen tanks
at public hospitals there aren't enough
medical facilities and they're finding
it hard to cope with the demand for
oxygen and other essential drugs and
equipment
with the country in crisis these muslim
volunteers say they want to join with
the buddhist majority in the fight
against covet 19.
we're worried because we're muslim and a
minority here
frankly speaking we're concerned about
the potential threats against us
we just want to fill in the gap and help
people
and many in need are taking up the offer
as they have nowhere else to turn
a mintant is a journalist following the
situation in myanmar they join us from
bangkok welcome
we just saw in the report there that
dealing with kovid 19 in myanmar is
pretty much a do-it-yourself project
is that accurate
yes many people are self-treating
covet-19 at home in the last few weeks
we've seen people taking to social media
to try to either beg or look for oxygen
and other medical supplies
we've seen huge lines on oxygen plants
as well as unfortunately crematoriums
and part of the thing for this is
because people are not being admitted
into hospitals which are
functioning at very low capacity right
now because of the civil disobedience
movements
and just people's distrust of anything
controlled by the hunter at the moment
and
because of the situation people are not
being admitted until they're at very low
oxygen saturation
now
as you said there the united nations
estimates that only 40 percent of
myanmar's health care facilities are
still able to function you've spoken a
bit about this already but how else does
this manifest on the ground
yeah so i think when we think about that
40 number it's also important to
remember that uh even at 100 myanmar did
not have amazing healthcare
infrastructure and many people
especially people who are um very low
income are we're not getting very good
medical care to begin with um and
because of the coup because of the civil
disobedience movement people are not
really able to seek medical help at uh
government facilities many people are
not willing to go to government
facilities and even those who do are
seeing huge lines because healthcare
workers themselves are boycotting
these facilities and so you see many
people getting turned away even for very
routine things not not related to cobits
such as just regular dialysis treatments
things that shouldn't be life or death
situations but are beginning to turn
into such
and we're seeing many health care
workers who are are now in hiding and
trying to provide care through
alternative means but are seeing
pushback and persecution by the hunter
what kind of persecution are we talking
about
um so because healthcare workers are a
huge part of the civil disobedience
movement which is the
sort of main non-violent uh struck
movement against the the coup and the
hunter
many doctors nurses other healthcare
workers have themselves imprisoned in
recent months we've seen
soldiers essentially do sting operations
where they pretend to be patients to try
and lure doctors out of hiding
and then arrest them
the head of the covert response under
the civilian government is also in jail
and we're seeing many many doctors who
are not living in their homes anymore
who are now sort of either staying with
relatives trying to find safe houses
and other means of trying to make sure
that they
are not in places where the hotel would
be able to find them
certainly a very difficult situation but
can you tell us how are vaccines
reaching the people in the midst of all
of this
so a little over 1.7 million people are
said to be vaccinated according to the
junta's health ministry
and a little over 2 million people are
or have one vaccine and this is in the
country of 54 million people and so you
know it's a very low percentage of the
actual population and
vaccines are being offered right now 1.1
million vaccines arrived in myanmar over
the weekend
but a big part of the problem uh this
legitimacy problem of the military is
that people
who are already vaccine hesitant because
many of these vaccines are
chinese-made vaccines and russian-made
vaccines
are unwilling to get these vaccines
because of concerns about these vaccines
but
we're adding to that another layer of
hesitancy because people don't trust the
military to provide
proper health care or they don't trust
or they don't want to be seen as kind of
acquiescing
to the authority of the military as a
service provider
now speaking of trust in the military
they are of course the ones also coming
out with the numbers and official
estimates put covert related deaths at
14 000 in the country now would you say
those numbers make sense
no i mean i think you know pretty much
everyone agrees that those numbers are a
huge undercount
one example of this is that over the
weekend there were about 400 deaths
reported um but uh you know throughout
this crisis or in the recent weeks of
the crisis
we've seen like huge lines at
crematoriums at cemeteries uh places
that we're used to
um processing 60 70 people a day um and
so if we're adding all those numbers up
in django alone at certain points in the
in the crisis we were seeing
uh estimates of you know five six
hundred people dying per day and those
numbers are nowhere near what the
official uh the records would indicate
a mintant is a journalist following the
situation in myanmar thanks for joining
us
thank you
time now for one of your questions over
to our science correspondent derek
williams
are the viruses related to sars cove ii
that cause sars and mers also airborne
pathogens
it took time and a whole lot of studies
before health care authorities were
certain enough to come out and state
clearly
that sars cov2 is primarily spread not
just via
larger respiratory droplets exhaled by
infected people but also via smaller
aerosols
that's because the means by which a
pathogen is transmitted can be a really
complex thing to prove
especially when it infects others by
hanging suspended in the air
but a lot of the evidence we have can't
really be explained any other way and
and studies have now made it the theory
that most experts agree on
when it comes to saris kobe 2 that that
it's transmitted from infected people to
others via droplets and smaller aerosols
mostly indoors in poorly ventilated
rooms especially if those rooms are
crowded and people spend long periods of
time there
what we know about transmission in the
coronavirus that causes sars is a lot
more limited because only around eight
and a half thousand people have ever had
it and all of them were infected
almost 20 years ago but but experts
think it's more difficult to transmit
the cdc says
that the sars coronavirus spreads mostly
only through
larger respiratory droplets
during closer personal contact either
directly
or via surfaces
contaminated by those droplets
that
and another major factor that that
sufferers are mostly infectious only
when they have the full-blown symptoms
of the disease
that helped authorities get sars under
control
through strict quarantines
when it comes to mers
we know even less about transmission
than we do with sars because even fewer
people have contracted it which means
even fewer opportunities for study but
but it's believed that people can catch
it directly from animals and and camels
are a prime culprit a human to human
spread is also possible through close
contact but
as far as i can tell
no one has yet identified the exact
mechanisms of that spread
[Music]
thanks for watching stay safe and see
you again soon
[Music]
you